we were lucky to get out of those escape
rooms alive
i need to know that the criminals who
killed the four people in front of me
are held accountable
we're hiding in plain sight in the
middle of manhattan we need to stop them
i'm in i know this is a lot to ask but
thank you for coming with me do you hear
that
hey what the hell is going on the train
doesn't come up
you guys have played the game before so
what is this
like a tournament of champions
[Applause]
look we all know how this works we
solved the puzzles or we died
ah false advertising must be pulled this
ad yourself is missing an e
so maybe we pull the corresponding
handles with a missing letter
yes
come on we don't have time
[Music]
this is way bigger than last time you
got to try something right
there's a special reason each of us
survived i can't feel physical pain
just imagine the kinds of puzzles they
came up with for me
take a picture it'll last longer get
some clues
this looks just like the lighthouse on
the postcard
[Music]
what makes you think they're gonna let
you walk away free again
[Music]
not ever
we need it we made it
hey i don't understand we're still in
the game
[Music]
you